and can you take us to the moment you're
talking with bill burr and Patrice
O'Neal at the same time is this I guess
you're used to it because you like
developed in New York but like as
comedians we hear these names and we're
like wait what
so they why starts when I moved to New
York so I was in Chicago then I moved to
New York with Pete oh I did exactly
crashing I did that with Pete oh it's
simple I barked at Boston comedy club
with Pete Pete got me barking and so we
stood on the corner and all that stuff
so that's where Bill and Patrice and
them would come in so Patrice was I
think would have been probably one of
the greatest ever is the he's like you
know I would if you could bring someone
back alive I mean I would bring him back
over anybody over Chris Farley like I
just want to hear what he has to say
about everything but I went to daru HBO
one night stand' taping they have with
the boat did a half-hour and I watched
that and I used to I mean I used to sit
and Patrice's Patricia Park his car and
I would sit in it in case so I'd move it
a cop came because he had parked it you
can't there's no in the parking and so I
was just sitting in drive around the
block of a cop came when they were
running their half hours I would time
their sets lay out time Patrice's well
he did not ask me I would just do it
like you know like the eager comedian
you're just trying to be helpful and
right I was like hey man that time I
know you only got to do thirty minutes
so our time just said you were like at
33 minutes and I remember he was like
all right and then just gonna walk away
like it was because they he didn't ask
for that and now that I know like in my
head I've never I've never done anything
TV was so I thought you had to be
exactly at that time you know but for
that HBO when I say be like yeah he
could have done 45 minutes and they
would cut it down to 30 like it didn't
really matter and you know and so but I
was watching those guys where as huge
Birds my that's my god that's my biggest
you know I mean look we now I'm frigid
BRR and you know I don't talk to him a
ton but but I've been very I'm member
Goodwin with him on the road and that's
awesome but he was the guy
that was huge for me like I watched cuz
he was one of the first guys where he
was a kind of hitting his stride in the
club's it was I remember the first first
letterman he ever did I was barking like
handing out flyers on the corner for
Boston on the club I remember turning
and I was like hey we got a great common
show and I gave one to bill Barrett I
was like ah man I'm so so I was like
embarrassed like I was like I'm so sorry
I just didn't I was just kind of turned
like I didn't know and then he was like
hats fine man he's like and he was doing
his first letterman and he was like hey
do you know I need to go run it do you
know any shows and I mean of course like
I'm in new comic so I'm like yeah dude
there's this show in this show and I'm
like telling him all the shows that he
could go to to run it but he was like a
big deal cuz I use the first guy that
when I came to New York you know you're
like world is open up to like you know
when you're 40 start comedy all you know
is like Seinfeld or Cosby or you know
whoever like whoever the famous Chris
Rock you don't know about guys that you
don't know who they are and then when
you get into comedy and you start seeing
people like I saw bill burr who's nobody
at this point not even he's about to do
his first Letterman and I'm like blown
away like I'm like this is bananas dude
I'm the first same way with Brian Regan
first time I heard Brian Regan CD I just
couldn't wrap my head around because
there's 2003 so he's not famous you know
he's probably selling out comedy clubs
are he is so not comedy clubs at that
point but I remember hearing it and I
just couldn't believe I was like how is
this guy not the most famous person
alive like I didn't understand you know
I was like this is the funniest human
being I've ever heard in my life
how is he not just how is he not like on
Mount rush it's crazy dude no one's as
funny as this guy so your world gets
expanded and you're like oh everybody
there's a lot of really really good
comedians and so then you get a sit and
I just watched Bill burr a lot I watched
Ferg
I mean obsessively I've you know I would
watch him at out the club's I'd watch
him I remember going to Caroline's and
he's not even had there the rooms not
even sold out at Caroline's I remember
is Opie and Anthony the famous
Philadelphia incident I remember
when it happened he came back and was
telling us about it before it kind of
blew up on YouTube we're guys that the
show was crazy like I mean he was you
know I've not that I've really ever told
him any this stuff cuz obviously I
wouldn't it be very weird and awkward
yes we've said we've sent alone - I mean
I've asked him questions like I've
talked to him about like those days cuz
I did kind of tell him like how like
seeing him and Patrice and asking about
just cuz I was younger comic watching
all that and asking him about that stuff
but it was but yeah I mean he was
everything man he was
he's a it's it's one of the biggest
deals for me was and that I still do
watch him is just to watch his path hey
hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath click the subscribe button to
join the hot breath averse and then
watch more videos to get even more
comedy tips